[MUSIC PLAYING]
JASON SILVA: So
for human beings,
existential angst
stems from the fact
that we are
creatures of meaning.
We are creatures of purpose.
We are creatures of myth.
We want to feel like
there is a destiny to our
like there is reason
why we're here.
And we've tried to address
this existential itch,
this agitation, through the
creation of beautiful stories,
beautiful myths.
We've created narrative threads,
religions, systems of thought
that have placed the body
mind in a larger context
that have made us feel like
we are part of something
greater than ourselves.
This is hugely important.
But what are we?
Well, ultimately, when
you break it down,
when you shatter the myths,
what are we left with?
And I read a great quote
recently that said,
that actually,
"we are dead stars
looking back at ourselves."
And when you consider,
we look upon the heavens,
we have the Hubble Space
Telescope blasting new tunnels
between the mind,
and the other--
as Ross Andersen says
-- and we back right,
and we are the remnants
of those stars that died.
The periodic table of
the elements, all of it
was manufactured in
the furnaces of stars.
So we are dead stars
looking back at ourselves.
I mean, this idea
is just astonishing.
We are poetry.
We are cosmic poetry.
And if that's not
enough of a story
to help you get
up in the morning,
then I don't what it is.